Florida Governor Ronda santz has dropped
out of the presidential race and
endorsed president kfe if there was
anything I could do to produce a
favorable outcome more campaign stops
more interviews I would do it but I
can't ask our supporters to volunteer
their time and donate their resources if
we don't have a clear path to Victory
accordingly I am today suspending my
campaign I'm proud to have delivered on
100% of my promises and I will not stop
now it's clear to that a majority of
Republican primary voters want to give
Donald Trump another chance they watch
his presidency get styed by Relentless
resistance and they see Democrats using
lawfare this day to attack him well I've
had disagreements with Donald Trump such
as on the Corona virus pandemic and his
elevation of Anthony fouchy Trump is
superior to the current incumbent Joe
Biden that is clear I signed a pledge to
support the Republican nominee and I
will honor that pledge he has my
endorsement because we can't go back to
the old Republican guard of yest year a
repackage formed of warmed over
corporatism that Nikki Haley represents
the days of putting Americans last of
cow Towing to large corporations of
caving to woke ideology are
over this is the smart thing to do and
it was inevitable to quote old Billy
Shakespeare there's a special Providence
in the fall of a sparrow if it be now is
not to come if it be not to come it will
be now if it be not now yet it will come
the Readiness is all since no man has
thought of what he leaves what is it to
leave btimes the primary was already
over after Iowa now it's super over once
Nikki Haley drops out it will be super
duper over but this was always going to
happen no candidate could have changed a
thing by campaigning differently we have
not seen a race with a former president
running for a non-consecutive second
term in over a 100 years Trump is
effectively an incumbent I mention all
Billy Shakespeare's line here as
consolation to the supporters of the
various vanquished candidates because
I'm a big Providence guy I'm very Pro
Providence I'm very anti- whining about
things that you can't change and that's
what the sparrow in that line refers to
God's Providence specifically Matthew
10: 29 are not Two Sparrows sold for a
penny yet not one of them will fall to
the ground outside your father's care if
you're a Christian you believe that God
protects and orders all things to his
ends we can and do constantly screw
things up but God is Sovereign and makes
use of his creatures as a friend of mine
from the Bronx once put it we do our
best and God does the rest Dan santis is
out Haley has no path the primary is
over everyone ran the best race that he
could whether you like him or or not
Trump is the presumptive nominee he is
better in every regard than Joe Biden
there's no use worrying there's no use
whining there's no use in wasting your
time wondering what if that will drive
you crazy only one question remains can
we conservatives unite beat Joe Biden
and put the Republican nominee in the
white house I'm Michael nolles this is
the Michael nlls
Show
[Music]
welcome back to the
show do you have a girlfriend well if
you don't there's a robot who is more
than happy to pretend to be a human and
your girlfriend and makes 30 grand a
month doing it we will get to the end of
civilization in a moment first though
don't want to totally move on just yet
from the primary I thought this was a
really classy move from D santis he had
to do it the donors weren't going to
give any more money there was no path uh
he didn't have to endorse Trump I
thought that was smart I think probably
here he's learned from other vanquished
candidates in especially in 2016 that if
you're going to do it do it you know
there's an old Yiddish expression I
forget how to pronounce it in Yiddish
but the expression is if you're going to
eat po do it until your mouth drips if
you're going to drop out of the race and
if Trump is obviously the nominee and
you you want to remain in the Republican
party you want to remain a conservative
you want to advocate for conservative
goals at the national level then you got
to endorse the guy he's he's the man you
know he's the man for the time might not
have wished that were the case but
that's how it is and and Dan santis did
that it was very well stated he's been
an excellent Governor I felt he ran as
as good a race as he could there were
problems with this campaign but I as
I've said before before I think those
were mostly circumstantial problems the
problem of a campaign that that is
attractive because of how trumpy it is
you know Trump without the baggage but a
campaign that naturally is going to
attract a lot of people who are
extremely establishment or who might be
neoconservative or who might be a little
bit squishy and they just hate Donald
Trump so they're going to the guy that
they thought could beat him even if
Ronda sanz's Chief pitches hey man I'm
even more conservative than Trump I'm
even more right-wing that was always
going to be a problem the one criticism
I will make of his campaign on the way
out is he closed his speech Ronda santis
with this line he said something to the
effect of uh success is never final
failure is never fatal it's the courage
to continue that counts some version of
that and he attributed that quote to
Winston Churchill and as with 90% of
quotes attributed to Winston Churchill
Churchill never said it there's no no
evidence that he did that quote is
sometimes attributed to abrah Lincoln it
actually comes from a Budweiser ad
campaign from the 1930s the fact that
it's from Budweiser which is the the
woke Corporation par ex Lance these days
is ironic and and sort of amusing very
few people are going to catch it just a
a word to the political consultants and
the speech writers out there if you are
ever going to quote Winston Church Hill
Abraham Lincoln George
Washington Google the quote just make
sure it's it's actually something they
said
because at least seven times out of 10
it's not and it can kind of be
embarrassing when people look it up but
all in all classy stuff good stuff from
Ronda santis and I hope he has a bright
political career because he's done great
great stuff in Florida some people now
are still wondering about Nikki Haley
okay the santis is out the croissant is
not going to happen the croissants are
done christe's out ASA Hutchinson is out
he was still in the race as of just a
week or two ago but ASA
Hutchinson has not end endorsed Donald
Trump he's endorsed Nikki
Haley the former Arkansas governor best
known for uh insisting that the state be
allowed
to that the state allowed parents
tweeted Out quote anyone who believes
Donald Trump will unite this country has
been asleep over the last eight years
Trump
intentionally tries to divide America
and will continue to do so go Nicki
Haley in New Hampshire hashir in the
nation frankly this is bad for Nikki
Haley a and this was already built into
her Lane in the race and her Campaign
which in recent months has really been
to lean into the fact that she is the
anti-trump candidate she's going to
attract the moderates she's going to
attract the centrists she's going to ATT
attract disaffected liberals in some
cases she's going to attract Wall Street
she's going to attract the coke Network
she's leaned into that part and so now
she's going to attract the squishiest
Republicans in the whole country
including as Hutchinson I think what
what Nikki Haley is thinking here is I'm
going to be the runner up to Trump
everyone else is out but because I
picked the anti-trump lane and I did it
the best because I actually had a
coherent political strategy even if it
won't be successful then I could be the
next person you know or if if God forbid
something happened to Donald Trump then
I'd be the person with the next most
delegates and then I would be the
nominee I don't think that's really
going to happen here I think the
endorsement of squishes like ASA
Hutchinson is going to make very very
clear to not only the Trump voters but
the DeSantis voters and the V voters and
the all and all of the conservatives
it's going to make clear that she is is
fully siding against their interests and
so let's say God forbid something
happened to Trump probably at the
convention they would just pick someone
else they would take Trump's delegates
and pick I don't know Tucker or somebody
you know they pick someone not even
running not even associated with the
race uh that that's the hazard of making
yourself out to be the the anti-trump is
you think maybe you could get a Unity
ticket like Reagan Bush maybe you could
position yourself as number two if Trump
really goes down in flames in a general
election but I I don't see any world if
if Nikki is attracting the support of
Asa Hutchinson's I I don't see any world
in which there's somehow a coup at the
convention and she gets the nomination
this time uh also because Trump has done
very well among
moderates the way that the media present
Trump he's the farri extremist Neo-Nazi
skin head Fringe or something you know
and and the normal respectable
Republicans they want nothing to do with
him but that's not not really true all
of the early endorsements for Trump in
this race have been from moderates
actually I mean you look at at
Washington DC it's guys like Kevin
McCarthy who's who's relatively more
conservative than some of the Beltway
crew but Steve scalise he's quite
moderate he endorsed Donald Trump it's a
a lot of those guys have been endorsing
him and now we're seeing not only the
unveiling of more moderate endorsements
for Trump but we're seeing them come
specifically from South Carolina so that
the senators from South Carolina Lindsey
Graham and Tim Scott are are relatively
Centrist they both just endorse Trump
ahead of the primary in South Carolina
in Nikki Haley's home state we need a
president today
hey who will stop the crime and
recklessness in the streets we need a
president who will restore Law and Order
we need Donald
Trump oh we need a president who will
lower our taxes and not raise our taxes
we need a president like Donald Trump we
need a President Who stands the American
people are sick and
tired of being sick and
tired we
need we need a president our foreign
adversaries are afraid of and our allies
respect we
need first time I met Tim Scott I I was
introduced to him and told that had
Senator Scott not become a politician he
would have been preacher and I I I
couldn't quite tell he's a he's a really
wholesome sweet guy and you know he
appears not to have any vices whatsoever
so that's kind of what I thought that
was meant by that but now I hear him
speak I say oh I see it you know we need
Donald Trump and and this is emphatic
it's a clear endorsement Lindsey Graham
gave him a clear endorsement other South
Carolinians did too Governor Henry
McMaster three of the state's Republican
members of the House did and Nikki Haley
in her own state only has one one
Congressional endorsement that is from
representative Ralph Norman so what's
this about this is supposed to be a
death blow to the Haley campaign will it
be we'll find out in one second we will
learn the answer to that question first
though when you want to learn you got to
check out Hillsdale are you a few years
or a few decades out of school and
wondering what the heck did I even learn
and what was the point you might even be
thinking I don't have the time to learn
something new well if that's you you're
not alone and it's not too late
Hillsdale College is offering more than
40 free online courses learn about the
works of CS Lewis the rise and fall of
the Roman Republic or the history of the
ancient Christian church with Hillsdale
College's online courses if you're not
sure where to start check out CS Lewis
on Christianity in this seven lecture
course you will examine some of Lewis's
classic Works including Mere
Christianity the screw tape letters and
the abolition of man you'll also see
what Lewis had to say about scripture
prayer suffering Joy Heaven and Hell the
course is self-paced so that you can
start whenever and wherever enroll now
in CS Lewis on Christianity to discover
Lewis's core lessons on Christianity and
how to apply Faith to your life go to
hillsdale.edu
kwes to enroll there's no cost it's easy
to get started hillsdale.edu
kwes to enroll hillsdale.edu
NS will South Carolina be the death blow
to Nikki Haley's campaign probably it
will be it it depends a little bit on
what's going on in New Hampshire so
we're we're in the runup to New
Hampshire the polls are disagreeing with
one another a little bit some show that
Nikki Haley is surging some show that
Trump still has a substantial lead if I
were a Gambling Man especially with
Ronda santis dropping out I would say
that Trump wins New Hampshire but I will
tell you I've campaigned up in New
Hampshire New Hampshire Republicans
they're a little bit weird they they
Buck the national Trends sometimes on
the one hand they're Uber libertarian
you know they won't R wear helmets when
they ride on motorcycles and they have a
billion guns a piece on the other hand
and they elect guys like Chris cunu and
and they they favor moderate candidates
sometimes so uh we'll see what happens
there I would still put my money on
Trump either way Trump is now up by
something like 30 40 points in South
Carolina Nevada Nikki Haley's not even
on the ballot uh so uh all in all it
would appear that we pour one out for
the other candidates because the race is
over now speaking of people expecting
Trump to be the nominee a lot of world
leaders outside of our own country are
are expecting Trump to be the nominee
including Ukrainian President Vladimir
zalinski who is very very concerned that
Donald Trump wants to bring that war to
an end he's very worried he finds that
rhetoric quote very dangerous and a
little scary and that rhetoric about
winding down the war in Ukraine is
making him a little bit
stressed in zelinsky's own words Trump
is going to make decisions on his own
without I'm not even talking about
Russia but without both sides without us
if he says this publicly that's a little
scary I've seen a lot a lot of victims
but that's really making me a bit
stressed okay I I think that the United
States has every right to make whatever
foreign policy
decision that we want to make on our own
without consulting Vladimir zalinski
especially since we've been the ones
funding this war from day one and if we
stopped funding it the war would be over
in 2
seconds I I think we've given Ukraine
enough money enough arms I think it's
quite clear there is no way for Ukraine
to have a total victory over Russia the
Biden Administration even which had been
very bullish on Ukraine has already
signaled that they're not going to push
for total Victory here the the libs in
all of the big liberal establishment
papers are saying you know actually
Ukraine doesn't need all of its
territory to beat Putin actually we can
give Russia a little bit so the the
negotiated peace that gives Russia parts
of eastern Ukraine which is what some of
us who are more realistic in foreign
policy had been calling for from day one
and we were all pillared as Putin
Stooges for that that appears now to be
the a consensus view among both
political parties in the United States
the inevitable View and selinski is
really upset about that well what will
what will have been achieved had had you
you know in this case I really hate to
say I told you so
had the Geniuses of grand strategy
listened to the realists from day
one this war would be ending in exactly
the same way it is now almost three
years
later except 30,000 ukrainians would
still be alive maybe more depend who
knows if you can even believe those
numbers
meanwhile after we've been told for
years that Ukraine is the Vanguard of
democracy Vladimir zinsky is the Winston
Churchill of our times he probably makes
a lot of quotes from Budweiser
advertisements too he this is the man
you know he's mobilized the Ukrainian
language and sent it into war he is the
great defender of
Freedom well there's a story that
basically no one has talking about which
is that an American
journalist was imprisoned and killed in
a Ukrainian
prison simply for voicing his opinion
that journalist is Gonzalo lra I'm
totally unfamiliar with his work I've
never watched a video of his I I take it
that he's popular on YouTube and in some
of the the manosphere and the red pill
circles bit eccentric and he was over in
Ukraine and he was arrested for voicing
his opinion on that
war and not sufficiently supporting the
zalinski regime and so they arrested him
they imprisoned him his health started
to fail the ukrainians didn't lift a
finger it seems to help him the US state
department didn't lift a finger it seems
to help him and then he died how are
more people not talking about
this all we ever hear about especially
from the leftwing press in America is
how those journalists they're the fourth
estate the Intrepid Defenders of
democracy we need to stop all those
autocratic regimes from silencing the
Press killing the press in this case oh
unless it's sininsky oh unless it's our
guys doing it unless it's the liberal
preferred
autocrats then they can they can kill
journalists they can kill American
citizens they can kill American
journalists doesn't matter as long as
it's them it's not that evil Putin when
was the last time Putin killed an
American journalist when was the last
time xiin ping killed an American
journalist
huh I I think I think what what have we
given Ukraine so far $2 billion no more
than that much more than that well I'm
sorry we're missing $1.7 billion in
military equipment I think that's enough
I I think we've given enough and I think
even if it makes zalinski a little
uneasy I think that the plan to wind
down the war in Ukraine advocated by the
presumptive Republican nominee for
president just fine by me speaking of us
involvement overseas uh really really
scary story a genuinely scary story over
the weekend uh several US troops have
suffered potential traumatic brain
injuries after Iran uh attacked an Iraqi
Airbase
that had US troops on it uh we don't
know exactly if the US troops have the
traumatic brain injuries and we don't
know the extent of them you know a
traumatic brain injury could mean
anything from a concussion which you
know is unpleasant but happens happens
if you play hockey in Middle School uh
or or or something much much more severe
we don't know so we should obviously
pray for the US troops and what this
shows you though is the risk to the US
interests of this on going war in the
Middle East you've seen Iranian backed
militants for the whole duration of this
war including obviously Hamas which is
backed by Iran you're seeing the hotis
in Yemen who are now firing on us ships
and then we're firing on the hotis
you're now seeing iran-backed militants
firing on us bases in Iraq where the US
is all of this brings me back to a point
articulated very well by the
mathematician benoa Mandel BR and it's
called Lindy's
law Lindy's law refers to a deli in New
York and it was not first articulated by
mandal BR who is best known as a
mathematician focused specifically on
fractals it was articulated earlier by
some other academic but he his version
of it wasn't that good Mandel BR really
really zeroed in on it and mandal br's
idea
was however long a person's past
collected
works it will on average continue for an
equal additional amount and whenever it
eventually stops it breaks off at
precisely half of its promise so the
idea being the reason it's refers to
this Deli Lindy's Deli is a lot of
comedians would talk about how long a
comedian's career would go
on sometimes you hear this this story as
people debating how long a Broadway show
would continue to perform I think the
author Nasim Nicholas talb put it that
way and the way you can predict how long
a Broadway show according to Talib would
go on is how long it has already been
playing for the longer the Broadway show
has been playing the more likely it is
to continue playing for for a long time
and equally long time Lindy's
law this applies to all sorts of non
perishable items and people and things
and it applies here to war this war in
the holy land has been going on for well
over a 100 days now
we think it it's only a week or two it's
not it's been well over 100 days and the
longer this thing goes
on the longer it is more likely to
continue to go on and that is very much
opposed to the US interest we'll get
into why in just a second first though
if you want to protect your kids from
the leftist indoctrination that is
rampant in the mainstream media I will
show you how start a 14-day free trial
to Ben key the New Kids Entertainment
app from the daily wire beny is the only
streaming app that offers highquality
family-friendly shows that reflect your
beliefs with amazing characters and
Timeless stories that will spark your
kids imagination with hundreds of
episodes that your kids will love new
episodes are streaming every Saturday
morning you can try Ben key for free for
14 days no catch no gimmicks no hidden
fees just great content that your kids
will love and that you can trust use the
code unlock at Ben key.com and you will
get 14 days of unlimited access to
beny's World of Adventure go to Ben
key.com and use code unlock at signup to
start your free trial
today what is the United States doing in
Iraq that can attract the attention of
Iranian militants that can then
potentially injure US soldiers what are
we
doing well we're the global hedgemon is
what we're doing we are still today even
with a rising China we are the
Undisputed world superpower and we have
bases everywhere and We Are the World
Police and we've got a global Empire and
that's just how it goes and Americans
don't actually want to give that up we
don't want to fight forever wars in the
Middle East but we don't want to give up
Global hegemony because Global hegemony
comes with all sorts of nice perks it
comes from the dominance of the US
dollar it comes with the ability to
travel wherever we want in the whole
world and not really have to worry about
it comes with the ability to do business
anywhere in the world there's some good
stuff that goes along with it comes with
a world order that is protected by the
United States so we like it but we don't
want to pay a lot for it in money and
certainly not in the blood of US
soldiers the war in the Middle East the
war that Hamas launched on Israel and
Israel has responded with and now it's
gone on for over a 100 days that that
threatens us positions because everyone
knows that the United States is the
dominant power in the world and Israel
would not be permitted to do much of
anything at all if the US did not back
Israel so Iran wanting to attack Israel
is going to attack the United States and
they're going to hit our they're going
to hit our ships through the houes in
Yemen and they're going to hit our
troops in Iraq and they're going to keep
hitting everybody and that's that's
going to happen for as long as this war
continues there are all of these
unpredictable complex uh events that can
occur so from the very beginning I've
said the US interest in the war is to
contain it not to allow the war to
spread I think V virtually every even
semi-reasonable person in the world
believes that after the October 7th
Massacre by Hamas Israel has the right
to defend its people defend its uh
territorial integrity and take out Hamas
which is an unacceptable security
risk but this can't go on forever and
the the fear here going back to the
Lindy effect is the longer this war
drags on the longer it's going to
continue to drag on this is probably in
the interest of the state of Israel if I
were Benjamin Netanyahu this is exactly
what I would have done some people were
arguing at at right after the October
7th Massacre that that Israel should
just go in basically flatten all of Gaza
be in and out while they still had
International
support I think what Netanyahu did is
actually much smarter which is if you
just keep it going you kind of drag it
out maybe there's a little truce there's
a little ceasefire then you keep
dragging it out you're going to fall
into the Lindy effect here and you're
going to be able to continue a much much
longer War which is going to allow you
to continue to Shell Hamas continue to
Pummel uh Gaza and uh uh not risk a
repeat of what happened in October and
and uh not have to pull out entirely
okay I think that's very much in the
Israeli interest I'm not convinced
that's in the US interest so what do we
do what do we do we're not going to give
up our the other thing we could do is
just give up our Global Empire and pull
our troops out of all of the bases all
around the world and just come home but
then you lose dollar dominance you lose
the world order you lose American hemony
you L you lose a lot so we're not going
to do that that is why through good
diplomacy you got to try to wind this
thing down that's that's why the Trump
campaign has been on peace that's why
the Trump campaign going back to 2015
2016 has been on uh pulling back from
from forward entanglements but not in
just a radical isolationist way in a way
where every so often we kill the
tamaranian general and every so often we
drop the Moab and every so often we just
completely destroy Isis but we only do
that every now and again to be
unpredictable to show you that we can to
show you that we're willing to sometimes
and most of the time we're going to pull
back that seems like a good foreign
policy in fact if we'd had that foreign
policy for the past 3 years probably we
would not be in this position in the
first place speaking of the future of
America we're already kind of up the
creek without a paddle you know we're
all planning for the future especially
presidential elections always make us
really think about the future I hate to
be the bearer of bad news hope is a
virtue and a demand but optimism is not
and uh we're already pretty well into
the problem and here's here's my
evidence 19% of
Millennials definitely want
kids n 19% of Millennials definitely
want kids 81% of millenn
Millennials either do not want kids or
are not sure if they want
kids four and
five young millennials ese
especially if they dwell on climate
change
concerns are considering not having any
kids study conducted by the University
of Southampton and the generations and
gender program
30% other than the 19% of young younger
Millennials who have a definite desire
to have children a 30% lean toward
probably wanting children among older
Millennials that's Millennials between
36 and 41 36% are certain they will not
have children 36% certain they will not
have children 20% leaning toward not
having them the majority of these
Millennials
56% probably not having kids and you
might say I was tempted to say because
I'm always trying to look on the bright
side I was tempted to say well you know
they're young these Millennials they're
young they'll come around but they're
not young they're not young 36 to
they've made their decision the the
time's up at that point it's not like
totally up if you're really really
focused on having a kid at age
36 and maybe you go through some doctors
and you're you're very uh intentional
about it maybe you
can
but most of the time no if you're still
I don't know maybe I'll get married
maybe I'll have a kid May or leaning
toward no you won't do that then you're
just not going to have
kids they're basically too old to turn
it around even even the younger
Millennials how old are the younger
Millennials 24 now I think Millennial
cut off is the year
2000 so they're 24 again you know
there's time to change your mind but
they're not 17 anymore when you're 17
you're say I don't know if I want kids
you know I want to go out and just party
and have fun and sleep around 24 I don't
know you're supposed to be a little bit
more of an adult at that
point and this is very sad for the
country because if you don't have any
kids then your country dies it's simple
as that forget about the ideology forget
about who wins some election if you
don't have any kids your country dies
that it's the whole story but also there
is something severely wrong with you if
you definitely don't want
kids I'm not saying that everyone is
called to literal biological Parenthood
that isn't true religious vocations are
not called to have actual biological
children though they are called to have
spiritual children
some people can't have children this is
a great pain for them it's a an
infertility terrible terrible uh
suffering goes along with that it's a
great great cross to bear but they want
and they desire the kids here we're not
talking about even that we're talking
about people who just saying no I'd
rather go to brunch and you know for a
for a dumb 22y old to say that you think
okay well you'll grow up but a 41y old
you know there's no growing up there's
no growing up and so if you don't have
any kids your Society is dead but also
if your society never
matures your Society is dead because you
got a society of children and then the
adults are going to come in and take
over okay a society of children
certainly can't govern itself the point
of self-government is that we're
virtuous and we've been well educated
and we are able we are so sophisticated
we have we have built and habituated
such virtue that we don't need some King
to to govern us but we're past that
we're clearly past
that not you know I hate to I I feel
like I'm doing the Ben Shapiro show
today I'm so negative on these things
but this is just
reality there something has gone
severely wrong with a culture that that
does not want kids at at these
numbers it just it just means we don't
want a future and so we won't have a
future because people tend to get what
they want so instead of having kids what
are people doing well some people are
dating
robots there is according to the New
York Post a new AI model Lexi Love not
the sort of gal you probably intend to
introduce to your mother uh creation of
the uk- based foxy AI that has been
specifically designed to communicate
with lonely
men and
the business has proven pretty
profitable just as a single AI model is
already generating 30 grand a month by
bodying the perfect girlfriend with
flawless features and you know she's
super hot and more importantly she
speaks to this audience that is very
lonely exploits that loneliness and gets
them to pay her a lot of
money now the
simple commentary on this is these guys
are a bunch of perves and they need to
stop being such losers and go outside
and you know touch grass or
something that's not exactly my
view desire is good okay sometimes we
conservatives we get a little too uh
puritanical about desire desire is a
good thing desire is what leads us to
God but our desires can become perverted
and when our desires become perverted
that the very desires that could have
been our great Aid in bringing us all
the way up to heaven can actually send
us down to Hell hell on Earth or you
know hell After Earth when we when we
take shortcuts th those desires those
drives can kill us actually you think
about Hunger Hunger is a good urge it's
a good drive because if you didn't feel
hunger then you wouldn't eat and then
you would starve and die but sometimes
our hunger can can fall into perversions
into gluttony into a desire for Junk you
know just eating junk food all the time
and then that's going to kill you too
it's going to make you really big and
fat and block up your all your arteries
and kill you you think about when you're
sleepy that's a good urge that's a good
desire I'm so sleepy I can't because
then you need to sleep and that's how
your body rep repairs itself and that's
how you get rested and that's how you
can go out and conquer the world but you
can short circuit that by you know
taking a little bit of that Hunter B and
booger sugar all right you can you can
go have a a little bit uh you know of
that 1980s nose candy and then you you
won't sleep but then your heart will
explode because you just be staying up
all the time and you're perverting that
urge certainly you see this with sex and
porn sex is a great desire it's a great
urge that you have it's what keeps the
species going it's what keeps a family
going a country going and the species
going but if you short circuit that and
you pervert that desire with something
like an AI
girlfriend and and porn which is really
all that is then that can that'll kill
you it'll make you depressed it will
certainly kill the species you know
it'll kill your family line and your
country and your your whole human
race the
problem is not that we think too much
about
desire you know I think think some
conservatives might we think too much
we're thinking too much about sexual
desires no no the problem is we're
thinking too little about desire we're
thinking too little about why we have
these desires and where they're supposed
to go and in part that's because we've
adopted this silly neutral libertinism
that says you know do whatever you want
just don't bother me about it but no it
it affects all of us if people aren't
having kids that affects me because that
means my country is going to
collapse it's the most extreme version
in the left the Libertarians they always
say well you know get out of people's
bedrooms it actually matters what people
are doing in their bedrooms to all of us
because if no one has any kids anymore
then we're either going to have to have
mass migration to keep the economy
afloat or the country is just going to
collapse overnight and both of those
things affect me all of these private
behaviors affect all of us because we're
social creatures and we live in society
and we have some right to to set the
standards and Norms of that society and
to tell dudes to stop giving their money
and to stop stop sing for blonde AI
robots that are destroying our
society my favorite comment yesterday is
from apathetically concerned
6574 who says when Jordan Peterson walks
into that goog he should announce I'm
not locked in here with you you're
locked in here with me I AG totally
agree I can't wait I I hope there's some
way I hope there's a security camera in
the room I hope I can't even IM I
actually most feel bad for the
bureaucrats who are running the Jordan
Peterson reeducation seminar because
that man is going to make their life a
living hell it is going to be really
really funny so turning back to weird
sex
stuff United Airlines is really really
pushing
Dei all the airlines are all the
companies are but United in particular
the CEO Scott Kirby has announced that
he's going to stop carrying so much
about whether his Pilots can actually
fly planes and he's going to care a lot
more about whether they're you know
black pygmy lesbians so right uh
so is a can a can a be a pygmy or
a vice for I don't know I'll think about
this later uh you you might recall I
think we played the clip on the show
last week or the week before this guy
has a radical leftwing vision for his
airline how is diversity and diversity
targets working into the aviate academy
we have committed that 50% of the class
of of the classes will be women or
people of color today only 19% of our
Pilots at United Airlines are women or
people of color and by the way from all
the data I've seen that's the highest of
any airline in the country white males
don't just dominate in the cockpits also
in the sea suite at United Airlines well
look at United I'm proud of the
diversity that we actually have in our
our sea Suite I think if you look around
Corporate America correct me if I'm
saying though so I this was just based
off your website the people you list as
Executives but out of 11 people three
are women I believe one is a person of
color um that's correct um but you know
in Corporate America I think you know
that's a low bar how do you raise your
own bar well a lot of this is you know
focusing on it we have uh programs to
one of the things we do is for every job
when we do an interview we require women
and people of color to be involved in in
the interview process bringing people in
early in their careers um as well uh and
giving them those opportunities and
creating a stronger bench okay that's it
I also mentioned last week Dei in your
restaurant means you care about
diversity more than your dinner Dei in
your school means you care about
diversity more than your education Dei
in the cockpit means you care about
diversity more than your life
I could not possibly care less if United
Airlines ever hires a single
additional black lesbian gender Studies
major to fly an airplane I'm skeptical
that uh diversity quotas will help
anyone fly the only thing I care about
in the cockpit is whether people are
good at flying airplanes and won't kill
me and 200 other people that's all I
care about don't care about how they
look don't care about even what they
think about a lot of can you fly an
airplane all right why on Earth would
United Airlines Chief among all of the
airlines be pushing this kind of leftist
craziness well our friends over at Libs
of Tik Tok have suggested one
explanation which is it turns out this
guy is reported a drag queen and there
are these videos of him doing weird drag
shows and all sorts of other pictures of
him doing drag shows that I uh won't
post uh I hesitated even to cover this
story because I don't have any desire to
personally humiliate anybody now this
guy obviously allowed himself to be
videotaped he's doing this sort of stuff
publicly so I don't feel that I'm
uncovering any private sins exactly but
it it is humiliating the whole thing is
humil the minute he put on the stilettos
that's a humiliating Act
and I guess the GU the guy's into
crossdressing or whatever
okay do you think that might have
anything to do with his Embrace of
radical leftist
politics I think it does I think the
lesson here for conservatives is
personal vices create political problems
you can't neatly compartmentalize these
two things a lot of people lowercase L
liberals classical liberals Libertarians
they want to compartmentalize life so
you say well what I do in private is
nobody's business it has nothing to do
with anybody and I can totally neatly
separate my personal views and behavior
from my public and political views and
but you can't you're a person you're a
per you're not two people even though
today people use the plural pronoun to
refer to themselves they say you know I
am they and they are me and I am the
walus goj but you're not really two
people some some others say my my name
is Legion for We Are Men many you're not
really many you might have other
spiritual problems going on but you're a
person and
so to to give credit actually to the
feminists of the
1970s when they said the personal is the
political they were right actually the
proof that they were right is that they
totally remade politics they were
completely politically Successful by
obliterating that distinction between
the personal and the private we all want
to have some reasonable privacy we we
don't want the public to rude on our
private lives and our families and and
everything of
course but that position becomes less
and less tenable the weirder you are
personally the more depraved you become
personally the more vices that you acrew
the the the the more bizarre your family
situation becomes the the more the less
able you are to have a private life
because that is going to so clearly
encroach on the public sector I mean the
the moment that you say say you family
isn't real and I'm going to live in a in
a thruple polycule with three dudes in a
billy goat and you're going to call us
all husbands and wives and we're going
to adopt children and we're going all of
a sudden now you're in you're in the
you've very quickly left the bedroom you
in the realm of major public and
political questions and if we have a
country of a bunch of cross-dressing
porn addled weirdos then you're not
going to have a virtuous polity you're
not going to neatly separate the the
private life from the political life the
the more you act
like a radical leftist in your private
life the more radically leftist the
politics of the country are going to
become because a country is made up of
people that's what politics is about
it's about
people a lot of technocrats and extreme
ideologues they want to pretend that
people don't matter people are just
statistics people are just automatons
they're just the masses to be led on no
no we've got the ideology we wrote it in
five bullet points on the back of a
napkin we don't we don't need to care
about no it's people man that's it
that's what it comes down to no but we
have the Constitution
Constitution without people who can
actually put it into
effect and a buck 50 will get you a cup
of coffee under Trump under Biden it
takes like 450 because of
inflation con a constitution letters on
a piece of paper doesn't mean anything
without people to actually put it into
effect laws courts of Justice it means
nothing without people who have
self-control and a deep enough education
into intellectual and habitual to
actually live that
out a nation
of of sex freeks is not going to be a
virtuous Nation okay that's that's where
we have to start talking about the
bedroom okay I don't want to talk about
anyone's bedroom but it's bleeding out
into the streets and it's weird and it's
making our country
worse now speaking of the importance of
people this is going to be a little
tease you know I'm a tease Dana White
who's the head of USC
just completely destroyed a reporter on
the issue of free speech and the point
he made was really really good but
conservatives are learning all the wrong
lessons from the
point because the point that you got to
learn from Dana White is not just what
he says when he schools this report or
owns him with facts and logic it's about
what he did at the UFC so I will give my
great praise to the UFC tomorrow because
today is music Monday and the rest of
the show continues now you do not want
to miss it become a member use code noes
kwes a checkout for 2 months free on all
annual
[Music]
plans